the next session uh this is a talk by
peter brettenoffer from data robot
peter's a data scientist software
engineer at data robot he studied
computer science at gaz university of
technology in austria and
bajaros university webinar in germany
focusing on machine learning on natural
language processing he's a contributor
psychic learn he co-authored a number of
modules such as the gradient boosted
trees stochastic gradient descent and
decision trees so let's welcome peter
thank you
test test
test does it work
okay can you hear me great so thanks
guys for the introduction
so the title of this tutorial is
gradient boosted regression trees in
psychic learn
uh this is actually joint work with
chili loop but unfortunately he cannot
be here today
so
the goal of this tutorial is basically
twofold so first i'd like to introduce
you to a very flexible and powerful
supervised machine learning technique
called gradient booster regression trees
or gradient boosting
and second
i would like to show you how i can use
it in practice using scikit-learn
so all the materials for this tutorial
is available under this
url
it's basically
if you go there
it's
gitup.com ppre-double t it's my username
and then you can see it already on the
on the repositories it's pi data minus
gbrt minus tutorial
and if you clone that
repository
but you get this basically one
ipython notebook
and the slides
so the first part of the tutorial will
be
in slides and then i will switch over in
the practical part to the ipython
notebook so it looks roughly like this
so the prerequisites for the uh ipython
notebook
are
basically scikit-learn
0.14 or newer so this basically means uh
so i strongly suggest if you don't have
scikit-learn installed yet uh that you
install the latest master version
because we made quite a lot of uh
improvements especially for the
three-based algorithms and you might get
slightly different results from what i
get because i'm running it using the
master version
and if you have anaconda 1.8
then
you're fine so it contains 0.14.1 i
guess
okay so
go back to the slides
good so i'm curious who have you that
has actually heard about the gradient
boosting before
okay
oh quite a large number actually so for
those of you haven't heard about it
before um
i'm pretty sure most of us here in the
room have used it today there's quite a
lot of evidence that most major search
engine providers use it for web page
ranking companies like google
like bing
or yandex
but it's not limited to this application
domain so in fact it can be used for a
variety of problems and if you've paid
if you look at the winning solution to
many prestigious data mining prices such
as
the netflix price or the geoflight quest
or the heritage health price you will
notice that gradient boosting is a key
ingredient in all of them okay and like
if you pay also close attention to uh
kaggle competitions then for me gradient
boosting is sort of the unsung hero of
khaki competitions like random forests
get a lot of the credit but
really if you look at winning solutions
it mostly contains some way or another
great in boosting
and just as sort of a geeky side note um
something very similar to what we will
see now
has been used
in the atlas experience over the last
years at cern basically to play to
detect interesting collisions in a large
hydrogen collider so it's really a very
versatile technique can be used for a
variety of problems
so
the outline of the tutorial i will spend
the next uh roughly 10 minutes on some
supervised machine learning basics
and then
introduce
gradient boosting focusing on intuition
rather than sort of mathematical
formulas
and the second part of the tutorial will
then be in the ipython notebook
we'll first
show how you can use it in
the implementation available in
scikit-learn
and we'll
finally look at a use case study on
predicting housing prices in california
good so quickly about us
so sheila he's a phd student at the
university of liege in belgium
his research actually focuses on
three ensembles
and he's a cyclone developer since 2011
focusing um
mostly on decision trees and random
forests
so he's the primary author and
maintainer of the decision tree and
random forest implementations i can
learn and me for my part
i've been doing python machine learning
for about six to seven years now i'm a
cyclone developer since 2010 working
mostly on uh stars degrading descent and
gradient boosting
so basics so
as i said this talks about uh supervised
machine learning and as usual in
supervised machine learning we assume
that our
data comes at a set of examples so
basically pairs of x and y
where x are so called feature vectors
which are basically like vectorial
descriptions of the objects which we
want to generate predictions so in the
case of webpage ranking
feature might be the number of terms in
the query or the number of overlapping
terms between the query and the title
tag of the web page or it might be the
page rank of the web page
the response y on the other hand can
either be a real value number in which
case we call it a regression problem so
predicting the price of a stock
or it could be a mutually exclusive
class label uh
in which case we call it a
classification problem like relevant
non-relevant or spam not spam
the goal in supervised machine learning
is basically to find a function that
maps from x to y and we want to find the
function such that the error in new
unseen x is minimal okay and this error
is usually measured by some loss
function which is basically a function
of the ground truth and our model
predictions
and very popular approach to supervised
machine learning it has been around for
decades and i think nearly half a
century now
are decision trees and in particular
classification and regression trees or
cart by leo bryman colleagues
and so a decision tree is basically a
binary tree
that recursively partitions the input
space using
so-called feature threshold functions so
here you can see an example for this
california housing dataset to discuss
later on
so in this data set the task is to
predict the median house price of an
area in california based on features
such as the median income in this area
or the average number of rooms of houses
in this area
okay
and
basically these
feature threshold functions or internal
nodes net tree they gate examples
through the tree
until they eventually end up in a
particular leaf and leaves contain
constant predictions okay so in the case
of classification this is usually like
the distribution of the
example of the class labels of the
examples that ended up in a particular
leaf or in the case of regression trees
this is usually the mean of the training
examples that ended up in a particular
leaf
and in everything that's follows from
now we will only talk about regression
trees okay so we only talk about
predicting
real valued responses with decision
trees
so if you look at the kind of functions
that just such an
regression tree can approximate so
here's a toy example so we have one
continuous feature x and the continuous
response y
and so the ground roof is this blue
synod function
and what i did here i basically
sampled the 80
yeah 80 training data points uniformly
at random from x evaluated the ground
truth and then added some random
gaussian noise
and as i said before
uh the
leaves of the
of the regression trees contain constant
predictions so basically the kind of
functions that you can model with such a
regression tree or piecewise constant
functions okay
so the thick green line here basically
shows you a regression tree of depth one
where you just have one split node and
two leaves so basically you have
two constant segments
corresponding to two leaves and the band
corresponding to the root node
and so the deeper you grow your trees
the more constant segments
you can assign which means the more
variants you can you can capture
in your data
so decision trees are
have one particular advantage so they
are interpretable right so you can
simply plot them look at them and see
how they derive their predictions you
can even generate rules that's basically
from them but they also have one big
disadvantage which is that they have
actually quite poor predictive
performance
so nowadays they are hardly used alone
but rather in so-called three ensembles
and uh streams normals usually sort of
average or aggregate a large number of
uh of trees
and they
roughly come in three flavors uh random
forest bagging and boosting
the first two actually quite similar the
sort of
average a large number of sort of
decorrelated trees uh decorations are
basically trees that sort of look
different so make different spilling
decisions but at the end of the day
basically
try to predict the same the same outcome
okay
so bagging for example
does this by
growing trees on random subsamples of
your training data
random forest takes this idea even a bit
more and basically also subsamples the
number of features before
finding a split node
and boosting which is a subject of this
talk differs quite a bit from the other
two so we'll see that in a minute
and basically all of those methods are
available in scikit-learn in the
ensemble package
right
so gradient boosting so
gradient boosting is a very flexible uh
non-parametric technique that you can
use for both classification and
regression okay and in my point if you
really combine a number of strengths
that make it quite unique and for me
so
in in some sense it's it's really very
similar to
support vector machines uh k-nearest
neighbor random forests so it's also
non-parametric
but uh
from based on this uh number of
advantages strengths it has it's really
for me like the swiss army hammer of
supervised machine learning and i really
sort of use it for most of my predictive
analytics problems a couple of those
advantages are highlighted here so first
they work really well with heterogeneous
data so that i basically mean data where
features are measured measured on
different scales like in this california
housing example we had
the
median income is measured on a very
different scale than
the average number of rooms for example
and it's in sharp contrast to other
machine learning problems such as
predicting whether there's a face in an
image or predicting whether a document
is an
email spam or not basically your
features are very homogeneous right
they're either like pixel intensities or
word counts
second advantage is they support
different loss functions okay so you can
pick a loss function that fits your
problem at hand rather than resorting to
some kind of proxy loss function so you
can do things like if your data contains
a lot of mislabeled examples you can do
things like robust
loss functions like uberized loss
functions for regression but you can
also do very exotic things like loss
function specific for ranking problems
okay that put a lot of emphasis on
examples higher in the ranking and less
emphasis on examples getting examples
right in the lower ranks
okay i think one of the reasons why they
are very popular for webpage ranking
and third advantage is they
automatically detect nonlinear feature
interactions so you don't need to hard
code those and you also don't need to
inject some prior knowledge in form of a
kernel okay and so they really give you
a state-of-the-art predictive accuracy
but they are still not a total black box
so you can still look into the model and
see how they derive how it derives its
predictions we'll see that later and in
this sense it's also very very different
from support vector machines on neural
networks again
but as usual it also has a number of
disadvantages like many other machine
learning methods it requires careful
tuning
it's also quite slow to train
but it's really fast to predict so again
i think one one reason why it's often
used in in webpage ranking
and the only real limitation of the
method which it shares with other tree
based methods is that it cannot
extrapolate okay so if your problem
requires extrapolation
you you uh
should rather resort to different
different technique or like
detriment your data first
or deal with this extrapolation problem
outside the gradient boosting framework
okay
so boosting what is boosting
so uh as i said before boosting is an
ensemble technique and it differs quite
a lot from other ensemble techniques in
the way it actually learns this ensemble
okay and you can think of an ensemble as
basically a mixture of experts okay
and a boosting basically learns this
ensemble sequentially so in a stage-wise
manner
but basically each member of the
ensemble is an expert on the errors of
its predecessor okay and one of the
first practical boosting algorithms was
other boost for adaptive boosting by
your friend and rob shapiri
and the way it works it roughly
iteratively rewrites the training
examples based on errors okay and i've
sketched this here so you have to read
that from the left so this is now a
classification problem okay the task is
to separate the blue dots from the red
dots
and what i did here in the first
plot on the left uh shows you a decision
tree
that has been trained on the original
data okay so it cuts roughly
horizontally through the middle so it
makes a bunch of errors okay you can see
for example the three
um
red dots
on the lower left side so we now upright
the examples we got wrong okay we
downright the examples we got right
and now the second tree instead of
fitting into the original data we uh
or we basically fit it to the origin to
a rewrited version of the original data
okay now the second tree puts more
emphasis on the upgraded examples less
emphasis on the downloaded examples
and we continue doing that for hundreds
of thousands of iterations and the final
model is then just
like the aggregation of all those
individual three predictions okay
so that's out of boost and we also have
it covered in scikit-learn ensemble
dot out of boost classifier or regressor
depending on whether you want to do
classification of regression
um and it wasn't a huge success so
practically speaking so one of the most
seminal studies that used other boost
was
the face detector by paul viola michael
jones in 2001
so i think it's
still one of the most highly cited
papers in machine learning so for those
of you have seen
have had a machine learning class you
probably know the picture
and financial period they also won the
girdle price in 2003 for the work on
boosting and other boost in particular
and so this caught the attention of the
statistics community in particular
jerome friedman who looked on
uh boosting from a statistical point of
view and his major contribution there
was to generalize this boosting idea to
arbitrary loss functions okay and the
idea that or the intuition that i would
like you to take away from this is
basically the one of residual fitting
okay it's a very simple thing actually
so again
we start here from the left so here on
the left now i show you the ground truth
that this is a regression problem
instead of a classification problem as
we had before
we have one feature x and the continuous
response y
so you can think of this as like the the
box office of your favorite movie right
so this
downward trend
um and the x the days after the the
movie launched so the first three we fit
to the original data okay so we get the
step function uh over here
right
and so the second tree instead of
fitting it to a
sort of rewrited version of the original
data we rather fit it to the residuals
of the first tree okay so this guy here
we have him spot on so the residual is
zero in the second tree same as this guy
here residually zero the other ones are
just relative because we have a constant
prediction here
so the second tree is then learned on
the residuals
and you continue doing that for hundreds
of thousands of iterations and then the
final model is just uh the sum of all
those individual three predictions that
we have
so and uh
friedman he basically motivated this in
the context of what he calls sort of
functional gradient descent okay and so
if you consider the case of least
squares regression so our loss functions
is basically just the squared residual
okay
and so you can think of the residual as
something which is proportional to this
negative gradient of our loss function
with respect to our current model
predictions okay
and so
the idea is basically that you do
steepest descent on this okay so each
regression tree is just an approximation
of this negative gradient
and then each tree is just a successive
gradient step so basically the whole
sequence of trees is just nothing else
than this
gradient descent procedure and the neat
thing of this is that now you're not
only limited to like least squares
regression so this
red
ball shaped curve here
but
you can also do uh
you can pick any differentiable loss
function and simply plug it in so you
can do things like uh this v-shaped uh
loss function here which is uh absolute
error okay uh which as you can see puts
less emphasis on extremely
uh sort of
mispredicted examples okay least squares
puts a lot of emphasis on on on examples
you got very
wrong
or you can pick like a huberized version
of this which is this blue curve over
here or you can do classification right
so you can just pick uh log loss for
example in which case you get a logistic
regression model so which allows you to
make
basically probabilistic predictions
or you can pick the blue function over
here exponents exponential error which
in which case you actually recover the
other boost algorithm that we had before
so it's a very general
view
on boosting okay so that's basically
how gradient boosting works and now
let's see how we can actually apply it
in practice
in scikit-learn so i will switch over to
the
ipython notebook now
that it works
okay so for those of you who have the uh
ipad notebook uh
i strongly suggest you actually run it
now because some of the
code statements that we will see later
on they involve uh maybe downloading
some data if you don't have it already
so uh this may take a while so just uh
like hit the run all
i think you can do this here cell run
all and then it will uh sorry
evaluate all cells
uh
so
i assume that
like who have you
has not used psychic learn before
probably mostly
okay many
okay good i i still uh go like to just a
quick intro because i think there are
two other talks later on that also deal
with psychic learn so i don't want to
um
duplicate too much but secular is
basically an easy to use
machine learning toolkit for python and
it implements
classical sort of well-established
machine learning algorithms for both
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning and the
sort of informal rule that we have with
circuit learn is if a method has
at least uh like 100 or 150 uh citations
okay then it's sort of eligible to get
into psychic learn otherwise so we don't
include research code and things like
this so it's usually really well
established algorithms
and among its properties it's
uh one that mostly stands out it's it's
licensing so it has very moderate
licensing it's psd free license so it
can be used in uh commercial
applications quite quite easily and
conveniently
and so the the the core concept of
scikit-learn is really uh
uh the component of an estimator okay
and i've just copied this from a cyclone
tutorial but basically an estimator is
any object that learns from data so it
may be a classification regression
classroom algorithm or some kind of
feature
transformer that just extracts or
filters useful features from raw data
and the bare interface of such an
estimator looks like like this basically
so it has two methods fit and
predict the fit method basically takes
these arguments a two-dimensional numpy
array
and optionally a one-dimensional
array
of responses okay the two-dimensional
array is basically the feature matrix
that we said that we that we specify
uh and the fit method basically sets the
model state okay
and once the state is initialized we can
derive predictions using the predict
function and predict again takes this
input a two dimensional numpy array x
which is
the feature matrix of our test data
basically
and so scikit-learn provides two
estimators for gradient boosting one is
called the gradient boosting classifier
and regressor and both are located in
this cycle learned ensemble package
and estimators usually support arguments
to control their fitting behavior in
machine learning they're often called
hyper parameters okay so among the most
important ones for gradient boosting are
the number of trees or the depth of the
individual trees and the loss functions
okay and you can specify those using
these constructor arguments so basically
if you want to fit
a gradient boosting regression models
with 100 trees of depth 3 using a least
squares loss function you can you simply
use the
use those uh arguments as constructor
arguments
and psychic learning put a lot of
emphasis on documentation so you find uh
quite extensive narrative documentation
on the website uh on on most modules
especially like radiant boosting but you
can also find extensive dock strings so
uh
in ipython notebook this is quite
convenient you can just like
put a question mark behind
an object or a function and it will pull
out the the docs string so here it shows
you all the
possible arguments
and hyper parameters that you can set
and like some documentation on
what are they used for
okay
and so this here basically shows you
self-contained example of how to use the
gradient boosting classifier and some
synthetic data okay
so you can see you basically pull out
some synthetic data using this dataset
generator from psychic learn
create a training test split and fit the
gradient boosting classifier using
200 trees of depth five to the training
data
and then you can derive predictions uh
estimator.predict gives you basically
the predictions of the class labels uh
you can also
get
put in the case of classification you
can also get
class probability estimates using the
predict probable function this basically
returns you an array of number of test
examples a number of classes and then
each component is the
class membership probability so in this
case a binary classification problem so
the first component gives you the
probability of the example being
negative the second component gives you
the probability of the class being
positive okay
and
also as a convention cycle learn all
attribute instance attributes
that hold the state of a fitted model
have a trailing underscore okay so for
example if you want to uh look at the
sequence of regression trees uh that
make up basically this gradient boosting
model you can find this in
estimator.estimators underscore so it's
a two-dimensional array number of
classes number of trees
and you can see so in this case this is
a decision tree regressor object
and here is uh maybe interesting to note
is that the implementation of
gradient boosting and scikit-learn is
basically mostly in pure python and
numpy so it turns out that the only
performance critical section in gradient
boosting is
learning of those decision trees those
regression trees and
here we use
the existing
implementations implementation in
scikit-learn which is written in cython
which is a kind of a python c dialect so
it's very convenient to create extension
modules
for python in c
and one thing also worth noting is that
uh turns out that training trees for uh
boosting is very different from training
trees for random forests for example
okay in random forests you grow usually
very deep trees and use lots of
randomization
whereas in boosting you usually grow
very shallow trees and hardly use any
randomization and this has quite a lot
of implications for
the tree growing algorithm so
since
the last
major release of circuit learn 0.14 our
decision tree engine now supports
multiple strategies to train decision
trees so you can see here we use
splitter
dot pre-sorted best filter which
basically does pre-sorting of the
training data before we grow the trees
unfortunately requires a second memory
copy okay so you know we need basically
twice as much memory as the input data
but it works much better for shallow
trees okay and so
so this is only available in in the
latest master version of cyclic learning
will be in the next release so if you
run anaconda uh
1.8 you will notice uh
actually quite a lot of quite a
significant difference in timings for
gradient boosting
okay so but now let's see how we how
actually such a gradient boosting model
looks like when we apply it to this
function approximation example that we
saw before
and for this is basically just
the code again that i used to generate
this synthetic data so it's just the
xenoid function with some random
gaussian noise and go over the code it's
not that interesting but just basically
oops
looks like
the result looks like this so we have
the c noid
curve which is our ground truth and then
we sampled 80 training data points in
blue and 20 test data points in red
and
here is basically uh the code that we
that are used to generate
the decision trees uh
so again uh from psychic learn you can
in a tree module you find this decision
tree regressor you just pass the depth
the maximum depth of the tree uh to uh
the estimator and then fit it to your
data and we simply using macbook we plot
the predictions
to get these uh approximations using
regression trees
now if you uh
do the same with a gradient boosting
model so in this case i use
a model with 1000 trees
of depth one
you get
an approximation that looks roughly like
this and the way i plotted this was um
i basically plotted the function
approximation after i add
additional trees to the model and in a
step step size of 10. so these are
actually 100 lines okay and you can see
the first line you can see it very hard
but it's uh
it's this
light line over here that looks roughly
like this first tree that we saw before
okay
and you can see this is a very call this
usually a high bias model so it's a very
constrained model it hardly can fit any
variants in the data so you can only
model very constant functions okay
so this again is a low variance solution
but as you add more to more trees to
your model okay uh you can see the more
variance in the data you can capture
and the less constraints you actually
have on the kind of functions that you
can model and in fact uh by using 1000
trees it seems like that we already
captured most of the variation in the
training data and in fact uh we also
already fitted quite a lot of the
idiosyncrasies of our training data
which is this random gaussian noise
component that we added in
and so this is a clear indication of a
phenomenon that is called as overfitting
in machine learning and it's like the
nemesis of everybody doing supervised
machine learning okay
and this is usually the price that comes
with model complexity okay and very uh
important uh diagnostic tool that you
can use for gradient boosting to
determine whether or not your model is
overfitting are so-called defiance plots
okay
and those uh plots basically
plot
uh the training and testing error as a
function of the number of trees that we
added to the model and again the number
of trees that we added to the model is
basically our proxy for
our the model complexity okay
so and if you
uh look at the training error here you
can see um
it's uh rapidly decreasing okay
and sort of slows down as we had about
100 trees okay but still continues
decreasing
and as we add about 1000 trees it's sort
of nearly zero okay now looking at the
testing error on the other hand
it also starts rapidly decreasing okay
but uh
quite early it stops uh it slows down
stops reaches its minimum at about like
50 degrees and then starts even
increasing again okay and so this is
this uh at this point the model already
has so much complexity that it starts
fitting these idiosyncrasies of the data
and by feeding this sort of random
gaussian noise component it doesn't help
the model necessarily to make better
predictions okay
so this is
a clear sign of overfitting is by just
looking at those plots and if you can
see a large gap between a training and
testing error
that's a clear sign of overfitting
okay
right so this in this case i use
root means no it's mean square error
good and one of the key advantages of
gradient boosting versus for example
random forest is that it gives you
actually very fine grained control uh of
overfeeding and it does that using
there are basically three kinds of knobs
that you can turn in a gradient boosting
model to con to control this overfitting
behavior and uh setting those knobs
correctly is actually like the key in
applying this uh successfully in
practice and i've grouped them in uh
into the tree structure the shrinkage
and uh something which is called the
husty gradient boosting and i will now
like go over those because they are
really quite important
so the first one is the tree structure
so basically here
as i said
the sorry the
the number of trees in a model is one
aspect of model complexity but also the
depth of the individual trees okay this
is intuitively
this makes sense because the the more
trees we have and the deeper the trees
are the more sort of terms we have in
the model and more complex
is the model
and
uh turns out that the maximum depth of
the individual trees control the degree
of feature interactions that we can
model okay so if you want to for example
model the
interaction between for example latitude
and longitude you need at least a tree
of depth two in order to accommodate
this so you need one tree node that
spits on latitude
uh and another one below that splits on
longitude or vice versa okay
but uh unfortunately you usually don't
know the degree of feature interactions
in advance but it's usually fine to
assume that it's kind of fairly low okay
so usually like treatment poses
um an interaction depth of four to five
i usually hardly go deeper than in
direction of six okay and by basically
increasing this maximum depth constraint
on your trees you also like it's it's
again like a runtime
uh
trade-off so you definitely pay in run
time and this is a tactics that allows
you to
increase the variance of your model okay
if you see a model sort of under-fitting
your data then you
might consider using uh increasing the
the maximum depth
of your trees okay another way uh to
control the tree structure is by using
constraints uh on when
a node is eligible to be basically a
split node and one constraint that you
can use here is uh which we call the
mean sample sleeve okay it's basically
a constraint on the minimum number of
samples
uh that have to be in a leaf in order to
be sort of to make a split point a valid
split point okay
and this uh
allows you to for example
uh
uh restrict the model to not create
a leaf for some outlier nodes so in this
tree in this function approximation
example that we saw before you could see
some funnels that the model did in order
to just like get some outliers right
okay by sort of increasing uh this
threshold you can uh sort of basically
restrict the model to the to do this
kind of
extreme uh leaves okay so this is again
one uh knob that you can turn in in
order to increase the bias so if you see
a model is sort of overfitting uh then
this is one viable way uh to fix this
okay and i've sketched this here
so
i don't go with the code uh i think the
the the the plot drive some of the
picture so again we see this defines
plot um the dark blue and uh dark red
curves are the reference curves that we
had before
and in addition to them to those i also
trained um
one model using this min sample sleeve
constraint set it to three so the
initial setting is to one so it doesn't
have any constrain on on on what kind of
leaves it can create okay
and
as we said before this is one way to
increase the bias of the model okay and
if you increase the bias of the model it
basically means that it
is more constrained so it has a harder
job to fit the training data so one
thing we would assume that
the training error actually goes up
right but our hope is by sort of
increasing the bias of the model we also
can reduce some of the variance of the
model by because it's still it's more
constrained and so it can capture less
variance and we can also see that this
actually is the case right so uh you can
see the test error
drops quite a bit
and so the gap lowers between training
and testing error which means that this
was actually a sensible thing that we
did
okay so the second
regularization
technique
that's actually really important for
gradient boosting
is called shrinkage and the idea here is
basically slow learning by shrinking the
predictions of each tree by some small
scalar which we call the learning rate
and yeah sorry there's a question about
the last slide do you
when you implement these in practice do
you change the min leaf size
do you essentially rerun this on min
leaf size from one to n right uh yeah so
the question is how you actually set
those parameters and uh i will come back
to that in in a minute if you can wait
great thank you okay a
second would make sense
given that it's a sequential algorithm
would it make sense to have the
capability of changing the tree depth as
we progress on the number of trees yeah
it would actually make sense uh it's not
currently possible in psychic learning
it would be
actually fairly easy to implement this
but
sort of
this implementation that you can see
here is sort of the classical
implementation and it only supports
constant
sizes
so you mentioned that you can change the
number of leaves based on the
interactions
i think yeah the depth the depth yeah so
that's important the depth controls the
degree so if you find out during your
initial data probing that there's two
interactions yeah is it like a
theoretical result that is it one is to
one or is it something that empirically
is known so uh
the the fact that the depth controls the
degree of feature interaction that's a
fact okay
we can we can show that um the way how
you actually set this and how you come
up with a sensible parameter uh i have
again to defer a bit later because
that's actually a huge important topic
but yeah yeah we'll come back in a
minute
it's okay
good
okay so
shrinkage uh very important um it
basically is um is the step size in this
great and decent procedure okay we just
make now smaller steps
and as a result the ensemble actually
gets quite redundant a bit redundant
okay so trees have to reinforce certain
concepts
but this uh
um so unfortunately by lowering this
this learning rate you now need to pay
in the number of estimators you need to
learn okay so it's it's an accuracy uh
runtime trade-off
um
but again it's very important so i again
show you here quickly the results on
on the same data so again the the dark
blue curve and the dark red curve show
you the reference curves that we had
before
and the light blue and orange curve now
show you uh gradient boosting models
with a learning rate of 0.1 okay
previously i set it to 1.0 which is no
shrinkage
and you can see now in order to get to
the same level of training error here
we need to add at least 200 more trees
okay so we definitely need to pay here
but eventually we get to a point of
lower testing error and actually much
more important uh you can see that this
model actually is is not um
we would actually need to run uh
much much more iterations uh and in
order to get to convergency okay so the
important thing is also that uh by using
shrinkage we actually also
we effectively combat this overfitting
behavior quite nicely okay that the
training error is increasing now you can
also see that the the
number of estimators as a parameter gets
much less sensitive to a specific value
okay
so it's definitely something that that
you need to tune
when you want to use those models in
practice
good so in the last regularization
technique uh it's called stochastic
gradient boosting is very similar to
what we do in random forests
so it's adding some randomization in
this whole procedure so it comes in two
flavors either by sub-sampling the
training set before you grow each tree
and you can do that using the sub-sample
argument
just specifying the percentage of
samples that you want to use to generate
uh to grow a trion
or the second one is by sub-sampling the
features before you find the best split
node so you can do that using the max
features
uh which is the same parameter that you
have in the random forest implementation
so
they usually lead to better accuracy and
reduced run time so also you definitely
want to do this and in my experience uh
usually the ladder works better given
that you have a sufficient large number
of features so if you have like 10 or
more features and definitely you want to
to tune max features rather than
subsample
uh for this example unfortunately
there's still there's just one feature
so i could just use the subsampling
subsample argument so like again dark
blue and dark red curve show you the
reference curves that we had before then
i have two more models one has a sub
sampling rate of 50 percent and a
learning rate of 0.1
so you can see here
um get quite a noisy estimate on on on
on the error now
but we do get a lower testing error here
uh
but unfortunately as you can also see uh
we now slightly get this overfitting
behavior here that by making the model
even more complex the test error
actually increases uh and so this is
already a sign that shows you that the
sub sampling rate and the
um and the learning rate actually
interact with each other so you
definitely need to have some
tactic to tune both values because by
just tuning one of those you might
definitely change the results of the
other one the optimal value of the other
one
okay so this is basically a topic now
which is uh given that we now have all
this pile of
hybrid parameters it's always the
question how we actually set those and
that's usually tedious in machine
learning and it's where you spend most
your computational cycles
and for gradient boosting i usually
follow this kind of recipe okay so i
pick the number of estimators
usually as high as computational
possible so this depends on
your hardware and your data set of
course
but let's say for our example like three
thousand something like this and then i
tune those hype parameters using grid
search so the maximum depth the trees
the learning rate the mean sample sleeve
and this max features okay and in
psychic learning you can do this quite
conveniently using our grid search api
so it's basically shown here so you're
from scikit learn dot grid search you
import this grid search cv object
estimator
then you define your parameter grid in
our case i
tune the learning rate the maximum depth
and the mean sample sleeve max features
cannot cannot use for this example
you instantiate your
estimator object
and then you simply pass the estimator
and the grid
to this grid search cv object you can
also specify a scoring method that the
grid search cv uses internally to find
sort of the best model combinations and
then you simply fit it to your training
data and what this basically does it
sort of uh exhaustively enumerates all
possible hyper parameter combinations
and gives you back
uh the best uh
the best parameter combinations and it
does that using a
cross-validation error so a
correspondation estimator so it
basically
uh
in a default version it splits the data
in three equally sized parts and always
fits
a model on two of the parts and
evaluates the error on the holdout part
and cycles through those uh free falls
and averages the results and this is the
estimator for
the estimate of the arrow for a
particular combination then it simply
picks um
uh the the parameter combination with
the with the least error okay
and you can access
this question yes so i see that and jobs
for is so it's all paralyzed all the
independent uh grid searches yeah
and uh what about the learning algorithm
itself is there any parallelism exposed
because they're training for us for
example yeah independent user data that
is a good question it's always a
haunting one for grading boosting uh so
just quickly this one uh so you can run
the grid search in parallel uh so it
does
uh it uses a drop lip under the hood
which uses multi processing okay so if
which uses forking which in case you you
have a large data set uh you have the
unfortunate um
happening that that it really becomes a
memory hog because it
copies the data into the new processes
so it's also uh like we also exposed
some of the underpinnings of the squid
search cv so if you want to you uh if
you
want to use ipython parallel you can
actually use this quite easily and hook
it up
with this grid search cv
um so the second question was uh
gradient boosting itself uh
is it possible to to run it uh
by utilizing multiple cores uh so the
answer is no in psychic learn not
the problem is that
we don't currently don't allow
multi-threaded or
yeah any kind of multi-multi-core
tree growing okay so in random forests
those are easily paralyzable because
those trees are completely independent
of each other so you can simply do a
parallel follow-up
in
in gradient boosting you can't do it
because
the the trees depend on each other
uh yeah so that's
that's definitely a problem in the
multi-class case there is a multi-class
case of gradient boosting uh there you
could actually do uh
some uh
some uh multi-core utilization uh the
point is that usually like
depending on what you're actually doing
if you for example are interested in
competing on kegel competitions then you
actually really spend most of your
cyclists here in model tuning which
means that you can actually leverage
your your your
parallel computing structure in the grid
search easily
second question
oh okay so first
uh so
first question is uh is subsampling the
same as bagging and second is related to
that is there uh you i noticed you
didn't include subsample as a in your in
your grid search as the reason for that
uh okay so the first question was what a
sub sample this whether it's the same as
as bagging
and in bagging i think you do sampling
with replacement
but i'm not sure
yes yeah okay and in in this subsampling
what i do is
without replacing
so i really just pick a subsample
of
the training data and the second
question i have forgot sorry some sample
is not in your grid searches right uh
yeah because i i hardly use subsample i
usually use max features yeah but i
should include yeah for for this example
i should have rather included this one
here to be consistent with what i uh
told you before
right uh yeah and this grid search v
object then uh holds
uh the best parameters in
this argument best params so you can
simply
set those best parameters and refit the
model on the training data and the
resulting approximation looks like this
looks a bit better what we had before
that was really ugly but uh this one
still you can see that
the approximation is actually quite poor
so you can see the
uh gradient boosting has a hard time
fitting smooth functions okay this is
just due to the fact that we use these
regression trees as base learners
so if you really want to fit very smooth
functions here there are better ways to
do this i have a question about batch
updates can boosting support mini batch
updates like can you memorize the weight
updates that you made on dependency
trees and then go back to the beginning
and incrementally adjust those weight
updates as you get a new batch of data
okay very good question so uh i think
people
understood it due to microphone so
mini batch updates so the problem is
really the training of the trees okay so
you can't grow
the trees using mini patches as far as i
know because you need to look at like
one complete
uh
feature uh yeah feature column basically
what you can do something along those
lines as you sketched it i think uh
people tried to
basically
uh you fit i don't know 10 trees in your
in your ensemble on the mini batch and
then the next three is on a different
mini batch and things like this
people
did that
to be honest i don't know with what
success i haven't tried it myself um
might be curious
so if you want to so this is more on out
of core learning right if you're
interested in all of core learning yeah
it might be possible
so people use something similar like
this if you have uh
if you want to update your model
if you have something like concept drift
okay so if your classification target
for example changes over time i don't
know the because the vocabulary changes
and you have some some spam classifier
then they add new uh trees to an already
trained model but i don't have any
experience with that so i can't
good
um right and just as as a side note to
this um
hyper parameter tuning uh
really a word of caution uh hyper
parameters interact quite a lot with
each other as we saw before
uh learning rate of course with the
number of estimators okay
the learning rate also interacts with
the subsample argument
and the maximum depth also interacts
with the maximum features of course so
uh
like tuning one of those in isolation
and then uh fixing it and tuning the
other ones it doesn't usually doesn't
work well very well uh so
for those of you who who
who uh really want to get your hands
dirty and and and and run some i don't
know kelly competitions things like this
i strongly recommend uh reading this uh
paper by greg ridgeway which is
basically the the guide to the gbm
package within our
uh great boosting implementation and he
has a
great discussion on on
on basically tuning and interactions
between those type of parameters so it's
definitely recommended
thanks
you mentioned you spend most of your
time tuning the hyper parameters but it
seems when you run
the grid search it tests every parameter
against every hyper parameter so you
really have the max
of the entire whatever grid search set
so what what are some of the issues that
come out after you're done it spits out
your best hyper parameters
now what is it generally
is that usually not the best set of
hyper parameters
no no
that's usually i mean that's the best
you you
okay so so
i don't know how related that is now to
to what you asked but uh in certain
cases so for example you're on the kegel
competition like this uh you get number
of um
uh of training data you evaluate your
model um
you do grid search using let's say
freefall cv okay so you only train your
model on three uh on two parts of the of
the data available on the third part
now
one thing is that the final model you
definitely train in 100 of the data
because you don't throw away any data
when you want to make predictions
um
so
given that you have one third of the
data more
you could actually train
a model that's more complex that has
more variance because now we add more
data to the model which also means it
can estimate those parameters better so
sometimes when you like
for calgary competitions i know that
people like when they make their final
submissions they definitely crank up the
model and make it a bit more complex
because they for the final fit they have
more data
but it's not something i would do in in
the kind of production system because
you always need data to just reassure
that the model is doing something
sensible
in the case where someone learns hyper
parameters and then
knows that they're getting like a tenth
more of data from the validation set in
in their training set like is there like
a general
kind of heuristic that they use to like
crank up their hyper parameters
uh this is just like my by play by ear
kind of yeah it's i mean
yeah it's it's just based on experience
and gut feeling sometimes at least
that's that's my but i don't know any
any heuristic okay otherwise
accept this will i tell you
how how noisy is the uh
the the spay i mean
enumerating all the different values is
not efficient compared to
climbing and restarting or you know
using a search technique especially if
you have a lot of data and this is
taking hours to run yeah yeah so have
you have you looked at like the contour
plots to see on noisy
the spaces in terms of climate uphill
yeah uh so that's a very good question
yeah so uh how sensitive it actually
boils down to how sensitive are the
setting of those hyperparameters okay so
if you perturb them a bit
how how does the model change if it sort
of falls down completely
and and that's actually a good thing is
that those parameters are not extremely
sensible and and all those have actually
like some
uh
some
semantics sort of attached like you know
other there are other machine learning
algorithms where certain hyper
parameters don't have any uh
clear clear semantics whatsoever i'm
just thinking of things like affinity
propagation like if you know these
classroom algorithms like there are some
parameters that just like if you change
those then it could be way off uh here
like if you change the learning rate a
bit usually doesn't matter much uh
so um probably the the one thing that
that has most influence
on this is the tree depth
because it sort of
uh
yeah changes quite a bit in the model
but otherwise uh no i mean i haven't i
haven't seen the case where like there
are extremely sharp contours uh yeah but
i haven't studied it very very uh
systematically so
um i have a question regarding the
comparison of this method with uh other
methods like logistic regression for
example so one of the nice things about
lr is that you can actually train
multiple instances of the same model on
subsets of data and then merge them or
aggregate them in some way like if you
want to train on
more data they can fit in a single core
you can train 100 lr models and then
just merge their decision boundary
somehow it doesn't seem like you can do
that with
trees of any kind decision trees right
or or is there some clever method of
doing so that's a great question but i
would take it take it offline if that's
if that's okay because i think it
diverges a bit uh from what we what we
did now but it's a cool question
right so
so based on what we what we learned now
and how how we can how we actually uh
like tune out our gbm models uh our
gradient boosting models and what does
hyper parameters mean now let's apply it
to some real world data just to see uh
to test uh our skills sort of in in
practice and what i picked here was the
california housing data set
so i think it it has a number of of
challenges that are quite interesting
for for boosting in particular so
quick outline of data set it uh so the
task is to predict the median house
value of census bloc block groups uh in
california so they're roughly
so it's the 1990 census i think
there are a bit more than 20 000 groups
each one has eight features like i said
before the median income the average
house age likelihood longitude
population of the of the group
etc and uh what we do here is uh we are
interested in optimizing mean absolute
error on the 80 20 train test split and
it's just to be consistent with uh other
studies that use the same data okay
so
unfortunately a data set is available in
scikit-learn you can just pull it out
using from the user machine learning
repository and here we just create an 80
20 train test split
so like i said there are some challenges
that make it quite interesting for
boosting like those challenges are first
of all
very heterogeneous like we have
heterogeneous features okay as i said
before the
the
the median income is measured on a very
different scale as latitude for example
but uh we also have very different uh
distributions okay so does it fit on the
screen yeah so
not really
so
yeah here you can see a little longitude
have this bimodal distribution okay
median income very left skewed okay and
this has quite some implications for
some machine learning techniques
um
we also have non-linear feature
interactions in particular between
latitude and longitude okay that's kind
of obvious that it could be a quite an
important thing to look at for this
problem
and third advantage is we also have some
extreme responses okay so here is a
histogram of the responses basically you
can see the mode is roughly
1.5
but we have very extreme house prices uh
about four times as high okay so
a model that fits uh
its solution based on least squares uh
might put quite a lot of emphasis on
those uh high extremely high priced
examples okay and like finally we
evaluate the model using minup slodera
which doesn't put that much emphasis on
this so
uh
yeah
so
it's usually better to optimize for
something
that's directly sort of the target
metric okay
and so what i did here is uh did a quick
rundown of some
methods that are available in
scikit-learn particularly looked at the
re-regression model non-linear svm
random forest and the gradient boosting
model
i tuned all those parameters using um
using grid search and then sort of
changed the parameters a bit just to
make it run
fast so in in a couple of minutes if you
want to re uh
rerun it here
so you can see the rundown basically
here
um
like you can see gradient boosting does
uh quite a decent job
if you look at the rich regression model
here uh
and its error that's mostly due to the
fact that uh rich regression is really
not not a terrible fit actually for this
problem okay so first of all it
optimizes for least squares which is not
good fit for for this data set it also
can't deal with feature interactions
okay
um and
it's also like it's not scale invariant
okay so we would
need to spend some time on um
on feature engineering and feature
transformation in order to
make it work a bit better for this data
set okay
now the non-linear support vector
machines in in this case a bit better
fit uh they optimize something which is
kind of similar to a mean absolute error
like this epsilon insensitive loss
but they do have a problem with
heterogeneous uh features okay so we
will also need to spend much more time
in in feature transformations
and things like this you can also see
that support vector machines are
nonlinear support like machines are
somewhat slow
and especially somewhat slower testing
time okay testing time is some something
that's relevant to you then
nonlinear svms are definitely not
not not a terribly good fit
uh random forest on the other hand
is usually a very good off-the-shelf
model okay you usually hardly need to do
any any kind of feature uh
transformation
but again this one uses least squares
as it's kind of target metric and which
is not like a very good fit on this data
set
for a gradient boosting model i
basically used 500 trees of depth 4
and for this dataset specifically i use
a like
microsoft
uh robust loss function uh called the
huberized loss function
um
uh that
is quite usually quite a good fit if you
have data that contains somewhat sort of
extreme or mislabeled examples okay
but
actually
this model is not very well trained for
for tunes for this data set and so if
you look at this uh
sort of defiance plot that i show you
here so
what do you think so
what do you what do you think what are
the hyper problems that you would
probably set uh in order to
get a better fit on this data set
so
those of you who downloaded
the ipad's notebook and and ran it you
can try to fiddle with some of those uh
hyper parameter settings
here is basically the the template down
there
otherwise i suggest you can actually
just look at the plot
and
and as a hint you can sort of check
whether you think you're in a high bias
or in a sort of high variance
regime
based on what we talked about before
so just red is test error for sure right
yeah uh sorry yeah sorry i forgot to
label the things right so the red is the
test error
blue is the training arrow okay
as we as we had before
so
no one
good so based on what we uh
looked at before is uh the gap between
the training and testing error is
usually a good indicator of whether the
model is overfitting or not okay
and clearly in this stage that
overfeeding doesn't seem to be
a major problem okay
so
um
in fact if you look at it
at the training era it's actually uh
quite high so uh depending on what's
your acceptable level of of error on
this uh on this specific problem so in
our case we just want to optimize for
the best possible score so we
it's a it looks definitely looks like
that the model is kind of underfeeding
the data okay so and a very good sort of
general
way to start on uh
when you when you just run like gradient
boosting model on your data is to first
try to make the model overfitting okay
and then
try to regularize the model uh
and get sort of the the variance
component out that's also something that
you do quite a lot in neural networks
okay if you
if you are into deep learning these kind
of things what people usually do there
is they they try to build a model that
kind of overfits the data and then sort
of try to uh use more regularization to
uh get to a better fit okay so in this
case something you can definitely do is
uh
there are basically two knobs you can
turn in order to make your model uh more
complex okay one is you can add more
trees to the model the other one is you
can
grow deeper trees okay
so let's let's try this
for this data set over here
and here i also set verbose option to
one then basically the model just prints
you
uh the current training loss it has
based on the number of iterations and
also the remaining time
um if you actually set the subsample
argument to something which is smaller
than one uh it will also print you
what is known as an out of back error so
it uses the examples that it doesn't use
to fit the model to predict uh to get an
estimate on the current error okay
that's something very noisy i hardly use
it myself but some people use it for
model selection so you can use this in
order to estimate
how many models you
sorry how many trees you actually
want to
want to have in your model okay uh
so
here are the results
so you can see uh
we actually dropped by another 0.1 so
another kind of
definitely
better fit than what we had before
so i just tried to get
another cell
and look at the diagnostic plot for this
so just got a quick question can you
talk a little bit about um
why the random forest regressor with
only 100 trees is so much slower in
testing than gradient boosting with like
600 or whatever you had here
uh isn't it i mean aren't there multiple
trees in all and also the gbt
okay so the question was why was the
gradient uh sorry the random force model
slower
a test yeah at testing time than the
gbrt model okay so the random uh
like one key difference between random
forests and and boosting models when you
just look at them as kind of three
ensemble models is the type of trees
that they grow like in random forests we
grow very deep trees uh lots of
randomization and in gradient boosting
we grow only very shallow trees okay and
basically the number of
cycles that you need to make for uh
for prediction is uh just the depth of
the tree okay so this is one aspect why
uh this is slower the second aspect is
that i spend quite a lot of time on uh
optimizing the prediction time on a
gradient boosting regressor due to the
fact that i wanted to use it in
production for a company i worked before
and
testing time is always difficult in in
machine learning in these kind of
applications also like you really need
to ask yourself what are you actually
interested in like do you want to make
predictions for single data points or do
you want to make predictions for patches
of data points and it's hugely different
and if you want to do the first one
which in our case
we wanted to do because it was an
advertising setting and we were getting
basically ads in
and needed to match them to to the user
query
there uh
the overhead that you pay already for
python function calls is way way
bigger than what it costs to classify
1000 examples in the c code that analyze
this so it's really
yeah kind of depends on
on
what you want to get
yeah
random forest also allows you to do um
multi
processing
use multi-processing at prediction time
which also again drops through an
abstraction layer which costs time okay
so this is some of the reasons uh now
this uh
this random force implementation
actually used uh the newest master
version which i strongly recommend you
you use so we make
tons of improvements generally made tons
of improvement on this one uh and it
also now supports uh multi-threaded tree
training so previously this was not uh
not possible we used multiprocessing
which had this memory problem that i
told you about and this is now gone so
what we basically do here is we
release the the gill
uh during tree creation
uh yeah so that's
definitely uh really looking forward to
the next release which should be due to
one or two months
uh i hope
good
so
right i just figured out that i actually
learned the model using uh
the old argument so it was just the same
plot that we had before in the same uh
argument so now i rerun it using six
depth of six and so you can see now it's
really uh like better than what we had
before and when we look at the defined
spot we should also see something which
has much lower testing error
yeah and a larger gap between the
training and testing error but again
it's like seems like we can even make it
uh even more complex okay
so
uh
right
really quite advanced in time so what i
uh
discuss
now it's basically something very
different so in the beginning i i also
told you that one of the key advantages
of this gradient boosting models is that
it allows you to do
uh
that is sort of not a total black box
okay so you can still look into the
model and see how it sort of derives
predictions and one of the first things
they usually do when you inspect your
model is you you ask yourself okay what
are the important features okay and what
how do they sort of contribute in
predicting your target response
and uh in the gradient boosting model
this is
directly derived from the regression
trees okay so trees intrinsically make
feature selection by choosing these
appropriate spit points
and
we basically use this information to
derive this kind of feature importancy
scores
and you can access those using estimate
a fitted estimator dot feature important
c underscore which gives you back an
array and in this case you can plot the
array
and you can see that like seems like
latitude and longitude are
very important as
is median income but clearly like none
of those variables is actually
completely un
unread
irrelevant okay so it seems like all of
them are sort of contributing and
predicting the target
so feature importance is very good to
get like a sense of what's going on in
your data
uh which ones are actually worth looking
at
which variables it also can tell you
something on
if there are costs attached with
each of those features uh which one of
them you actually really want to compute
and which one you don't actually don't
need to compute
question
is there a way to get confidence
intervals around the importance or
in other words uh see if there's certain
is there a way to kind of quantitatively
say that this this feature should be
dropped
okay uh
unfortunately not so i'm not an expert
on this she'll he actually does his phd
on this um so uh i strongly if you're
really interested in this i strongly
recommend you you get in touch with him
he can tell you much much more about
this there are multiple versions to
actually do these importances for three
models
uh
this one is is just based on uh the the
criteria that we use to grow the trees
okay there are permutation based tests
which probably give you a similar
information what you requested but i
actually to be honest i don't know any
uh uncertainty sort of intervals that
you can attach to those uh importances
uh yeah um but again like this
importance is just tell you one part of
the story uh they don't tell you
anything about how those features
actually interact with the response or
how they even interact with with each
other okay and in order to do this uh
you can look at partial dependency plots
and that's
gradient boosting is currently the only
model in cyclic loan that supports
partially penalty plots but
in principle that's nothing that's
inherent to to to gradient boosting you
can actually do this with any kind of
model
but it's
usually very computationally intense but
for three models it's very simple to do
because the trees is kind of a summary
of your whole training data and so you
can derive those quite easily and what
they basically show is they show you uh
the relationship
um
between the response and sort of a
number of features you you condition on
and marginalizing overall a lot of
features okay so you can see things like
for example if you look at the median
income at the partial dependency of the
median income
you can see that
there's roughly a linear relationship
between the median income and the log
median
house value okay
or you can see
that
looking at average occupancy is somewhat
a proxy of i think of of of how sort of
close to a city or how urban sort of an
area is
um
because like in cities usually like
probably uh
mostly singles and and
families mostly live in suburban areas
but you can see that in those like areas
where the average occupancy is low tends
to be a higher
a higher house price okay and you can
also look at two dimensional partial
dependency plots like this one over here
that shows us the house age and versus
the average occupancy and the partial
dependency is just the contour
so looking at house h itself it seems
like it doesn't have any effect on the
on the target response okay but looking
at this two dimensional partial
dependency plots you can see something
pretty interesting which is that um
if the average occupancy has a value of
2.5 or higher it seems like the house h
doesn't have any effect on on the target
response okay but actually if you're
in an area that's
so my assumptions some some kind of
urban so you have you have a lower
average occupancy the house age actually
has an effect on on on on the house
price and the older the house
the higher price basically
okay and so in psychic learn we have
like a convenience plotting function
like basically looks like this you pass
it the estimator the original training
data and the number of
features uh
you're interested in
uh and it creates those try this plot
but there are also some
low-level functions that you can use to
generate map overlays and 3d plots
things like this so what i did here is
use base map which is kind of this
geoplotting for matplotlib toolkit to
plot the partial dependency of latitude
and longitude so nice thing here
what you can see is that the model sort
of nicely captures that
all the things being equal house prices
at the coast are higher than any
interior okay
it kind of makes sense
and you can also like zoom into the bay
area here
and yeah
i'm not from here so i can tell whether
that's whether that's
something sensible i tried to double
check with trulia but looks a bit
different
uh
yeah
good
so any question to partial dependency
plots
no how am i doing
time okay good
so
i just have basically two more uh things
to show you one thing is uh about
performance
uh
so it's something that people are
probably interested in
uh
there is uh basically one implementation
that's
uh
where secular's gradient boosting model
is is is uh kind of uh based on where i
looked very closely how they do it which
is uh basically a reference
implementation of gradient boosting in
in r which is the gbm package
and so here i show you some benchmarks
on uh training time and testing time and
predictive accuracy over
a number of data sets okay and this one
uses a new version uh again the latest
version of circuit learning current
master which
allows you also to create
to train uh trees very differently in
the kind of shape that they have so gbm
is something very special that's hardly
documented it's
the way it creates trees is not as
complete binary trees okay where we just
grow them until a certain depth but what
they do rather is they grow the tree's
depth first
so they try to grow branches because at
the end of the day only the branch is
interesting
because it determines the interaction
depth and the interaction depth is the
only thing we're interested in
so the new version the current master
version of psychic line also allows you
to create trees in this kind of fashion
instead of max leaves it uses a
different argument which is called the
number of
leaf nodes that you want to have and
basically interaction depth is the
number of leaf nodes
minus one
um
that being said uh given the fact that
we have this feature now available
we get very similar performance to gbm
package uh because previously i got a
lot of feature requests where they said
okay i ran this model in gbm and it gave
this results and then i learned it in
psychic learning it was totally
different
so now they should give very similar
results so we can also now given that
they are very similar we can look at the
training time and testing time
performance
testing time i wouldn't look too much at
because of the problems we outlined
before training time is more interesting
probably because it tells you that uh if
you make only performance uh
evaluations on one single data set you
don't know uh you hardly know anything
uh so
here basically the blue
bar shows you gbm and it's normalized to
one okay and so if the green bar is
lower it tells you circuit learn is
faster the green bar is higher it shows
that it's slower
um
and so you can see that
the story is kind of mixed okay for some
it does way worse like for example 10.2
okay that's a synthetic data set it's
actually pretty small
and it also it's from based on like
random number generators so all the
feature values are
completely unique okay so we have lots
and lots of potential split points and
it seems like the number of spit points
has quite a lot of implications on the
runtime of the algorithm but if you look
at like
more realistic data sets like the yahoo
learning to rank data set that was a
competition that yahoo put out on web
page ranking you can see that
cyclic loan is like 40 faster
on this one and it's like a large data
set so i actually had to
subsample it in order to make gbm run
uh on it
and also
this data set here expedia is again a
kegel competition
it's also roughly 40 faster
and cover type is also quite interesting
it has like half a million examples and
most of them are binary features
so
uh you see there are only a few
potential split points so this has quite
a lot of implications on tree building
psychic learning it definitely seems
like it's faster for
data sets with indicator features things
like this can you give us a sense of how
many uh features are in these data sets
is that why that may be that big peak
there in train time is it linear or
nonlinear the number of features good
question yeah so um there are basically
three characteristics we're interested
in
uh how how we could uh group them the
number of samples the number of features
and uh
what i just outlined now is the number
of potential split points that you can
use
when it comes to the number of features
then bioresponse for example is one of
those examples that has that is a wide
data set that has a very few examples
okay it's a couple of thousand
features
then uh also our keen and madelone
they're they're basically synthetic data
sets from the nips competition on
feature selection and one of them is has
very few features
and a bunch of irrelevant ones and very
large data a number of these examples
and the other ones is
is just the opposite it has just a few
number of examples and a ton of features
and it seems like that that's not
necessarily the case so
this is not what drives it mostly uh so
the most of the difference in my point
of view it's on the one hand and
overhead that we pay in psychic learn
for
probably some abstractions we use and
the second one is the number of
potential split points that seems to be
problematic
right
um
about two minutes two minutes okay so
now quickly just go over some
tips and tricks pics of the trade uh so
uh that's something that pops up on the
mailing list quite a lot uh categorical
features so
i only talked about numeric features for
now okay but often you if you have data
mining problems you have categorical
features okay such as
uh so this example i had was from a
competition on uh predicting
flight arrival times okay and one of the
features was like uh the the type
of the aircraft okay and it's likely an
uh categorical feature so there's no
inherent ordering of
of the values okay so and what you what
you usually suggest in circuit learning
is um
is to use uh one hot encoding where you
basically create as many features as
there are um categorical variables
uh levels as there are levels in the
categorical variable
but this usually has a huge
overhead then in terms of memory and in
terms of runtime because tree growing is
linear in the number of features
and
it doesn't support sparse data yet so
creating these kind of indicator
matrices is quite costly
but
it works really well if you do what is
called ordinal encoding so you just
assign a random number to to your level
okay
and
given that you grow your trees deep
enough it actually will figure it out
kind of it is way faster and it works
extremely so i strongly suggest you use
this if you have
uh to deal with categorical features
and the second sort of
trick
which might help quite a bit is i told
you that gbm sort of automatically
detects feature interactions
it can definitely get some help uh uh it
appreciates if you if you add some some
prior knowledge in there so if you uh
have
things like differences that might be
important for your model like
in the flight com in this flight example
it was often the
um the current time of the of the
aircraft and the scheduled arrival okay
which tells you something about okay uh
how far um
yeah how far off it
it might be based on its location okay
then
in order to approximate this gbm
actually
needs to do quite a lot of work okay so
this on the left hand side you can see
uh if you want to approximate the
function x min x minus x so one feature
minus the other one uh using 10 trees it
actually is a very poor approximation so
you need quite a lot of
uh quite a lot of capacity already to
model something like this
um
and here is a gradient boosting model or
any kind of three tree uh ensemble is
very different from something like a
deep neural net okay so deep learner
like could learn these kind of features
in an underlying layer as an abstraction
and reuse this abstraction in higher up
layers
uh a tree model can't do this right so
it has to sort of instantiate this again
and again and again and so it spends
quite a lot of capacity on on modeling
these kind of things
so if you know that this is kind of
important
uh
based on kind of domain knowledge you
should like make this explicit and add
it
to the model
okay
so
right basically to to summarize um
presented uh like gradient boosting is
really a flexible non-parametric
classification and regression technique
and it's really applicable to a variety
of problems so
i've seen it being applied to problems
in the audio domain
in webpage ranking even in a
distribution model for
environmental niches
and we really have like a solid sort of
battle one implementation in psychic
learn that has been used in
in is used in academia and even industry
uh and it's also quite heavily used in
at kaggle so i think there are at least
eight competitions that have been won
using
this model
okay so thanks for your attention
um i i was surprised by the graph you
showed about feature interactions yeah
what was was that artificially
constrained to only be a depth of of one
is is that is that why it couldn't they
couldn't find it with um uh for this one
i i used uh depth of two for the left
one definitely tuna and it still
couldn't find it okay yeah
all right thanks
any other questions
do you guys handle missing data
and follow-up question is what is the
splitting uh formula used to decide a
split is it like genie index or what do
you use
good so to the second question first
because that's the important one uh
we we uh we only use like they're only
used uh
ingredient boosting you only use
regression trees
so no genie index but rather we use uh
variance
yeah minimizing variance so basically
find this bit point where the two the
variances of the two partitions that you
create this is minimal
but it's a very good question because
there are many ways to do this and the
current master version differs from the
last stable release in that it penalizes
um
imbalance splits more
it gives quite
could give quite different results
that's the way the gbm does it as well
and the first question
was
missing data yeah scikit learn none of
the psychic learning models does support
missing data or
categorical variables intrinsically okay
so you also need to you always need to
deal with them outside
so in
uh i mean what i usually do is median
imputation what other people do uh with
because with media imputation you can
sort of uh trick the model of them quite
a bit
so what i usually do is like immediate
imputation and an additional like uh
binary feature that just said okay it
was imputed was not imputed
and but what other people also do is
they just impute some huge number that
is not not possible
in in the data set as such like minus i
don't know
9
e to the power 40. and um
and the model will still like figure out
that those are missing values and it
treats them differently so we don't do
any intrinsic handling of missing
features like surrogate features
can you talk a little bit about loss
functions i guess uber does seem to work
well but um
yeah for the noisy cases yeah it might
be other those functions so uh for the
noisy cases we currently just have two
of them uh one is uh least absolute
deviation which is this absolute error
that we had before this v shaped
function and the second one is uh the
supervised loss function which is just
like
basically a
uh a combination of the of the least
squares and uh and and at least absolute
deviation uh so based on uh the
quantiles uh of your errors so i think
within you can specify that but
within uh
the
innermost 80 80 of the data you use
least squares and on the extremities you
used at least absolutely er
next uh and
currently actually we hardly support any
loss functions in scikit-learn we just
do a
bunch of for regression uh and only one
for classification and but it's it's
very easy actually to to implement new
loss functions you just need to
specify some classes in class interfaces
actually
uh and current people are currently
working on uh adding ranking loss
functions uh to this so there's a
pull request out there and hopefully it
will be merged in the next month
okay thanks
you